‏v
[Silence]
‏s
الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد
قامت الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله
الا
[Silence]
الله استقيموا واستووا تراصوا واعتدلوا
يرحمكم
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصرا راط المستقيم صراط
الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين انما السبيل على الذين
يستاذنك وهم اغنياء
رضوا بان يكونوا مع الخوالف وطبع الله على
قلوبهم فهم لا
يعلمون يعتذرون اليكم اذا رجعتم اليهم قل
لا تعتذروا لن نؤمن لكم قد نبانا الله من
اخباركم وسيرى الله عملكم
ورسوله وسيرى الله عملكم
ورسوله ثم تردون الى عالم الغيب والشهاده
فينبئكم بما كنتم
تعملون سيحلفون بالله لكم اذا انقلبتم
اليهم لتعرضوا عنهم فاعرضوا عنهم انهم رجس
وماواهم
جهنم وماواهم جهن
جزاء بما كانوا
يكسبون يحلفون لكم لترضوا عنهم فان ترضوا
عنهم فان الله لا يرضى عن القوم
الفاسقين الاعراب اشد كفرا ونفاقا واجدر
الا يعلموا حدود ما انزل الله على رسول
والله عليم
حكيم ومن الاعراب من يتخذ ما ينفق مغرما
ويتربص بكم
الدوائر عليهم
دائره
السوء والله سميع
عليم ومن الاعراب من يؤمن بالله واليوم
الاخر ويتخذ ما
ينفق قربات عند الله وصلوات
الرسول وصلوات الرسول الا انها قربه لهم
سيدخلهم الله في رحمته ان الله غفور
رحيم والسابقون الاولون من المهاجرين
والانصار والذين اتبعوهم باحس
رضي الله عنهم ورضوا
عنه رضي الله عنهم ورضوا عنه واعد لهم
جنات تجري تحتها الانهار خالدين فيها
ابدا ذلك الفوز
العظيم وممن حولكم من الاعراب
منافقون ومن اهل المدينه مردوا على
النفاق
لا تعلمهم نحن نعلمهم سنعذبهم
مرتين سنعذبهم
مرتين ثم يردون الى عذاب
عظيم واخرون اعترفوا بذنوبهم خلطوا عملا
صالحا واخر
سيئا عسى الله ان يتوب عليهم ان الله غفور
الرحيم خذ من اموالهم صدقه تطهرهم وت
تطهرهم
وتزكيهم بها وصل عليهم ان صلاتك سكن لهم
والله سميع
عليم الم يعلموا ان الله هو يقبل التوبه
عن عباده ويعفو عن
السيئات
وان الله هو التو وياخذ الصدقات وان الله
هو التواب
الرحيم وقل اعملوا فسيرى الله عملكم
ورسوله
والمؤمنون وستردون الى عالم الغيب
والشهاده
فينبئكم بما
كنتم
تعملون الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
واخرون مرجون لامر الله اما يعذبهم واما
يتوب عليهم والله عليم
حكيم والذين اتخذوا مسجدا ضرارا وكفرا
وتفريقا بين المؤمنين وارصاد لمن حارب
الله ورسوله من قبل وليحلفن
ان اردنا الا الحسنى والله يشهد انهم
لكاذبون لا تقم فيه ابدا لمسجد اسس على
التقوى من اول يوم احق ان تقوم
فيه فيه رجال يحبون ان يتطهروا والله يحب
المطهرين افمن اسس بنيانه على تقوى من
الله ورضوان خير ام منن اسس بنيانه على
شفا جر فينهار فانهار به في نار
جهنم والله لا يهدي القوم
الظالمين لا يزال بنيانهم الذي بنوا
ريبه في قلوبهم الا ان تقطع قلوبهم والله
عليم
حكيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر بس
الله الحمد لله رب
العالم
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
السلام عل
اللهه all
usic either
swit or put your ringers on to complete
silence if you have little ones with you
they need to either go to bab or they
need to with
can make kidss
‏darks acr hall from elevator there two
rooms available for babysitters and the
kids can go there for free
[Silence]
charge
بسم الله
[Silence]
ال
‏s
[Silence]
‏r
استقيموا واستو صلاه
القيام الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ان الله اشترى من المؤمنين انفسهم
واموالهم بان لهم
الجنه يقاتلون في سبيل الله فيقتلون
ويقتلون وعدا عليه حقا في التوراه
والانجيل
والقران و اوفى بعهده من
الله فاستبشروا ببيعكم الذي بايعتم به
وذلك هو الفوز
العظيم
التائبون العابدون الحامدون
السائحون الراكعون
الساجدون الامرون بالمعروف
والناهون عن المن كر والحافظون لحدود
الله وبشر
المؤمنين ما كان للنبي والذين امنوا ان
يستغفروا للمشركين ولو كانوا اولي قربى من
بعد ما تبين لهم انهم اصحاب
الجحيم وما كان استغفار ابراهيم ابيه الا
عن موعده وعدها
اياه فلما تبين له انه عدو لله تبرا منه
ان ابراهيم لاواه
حليم وما كان الله ليضل قوما بعد اذ هداهم
حتى يبين لهم ما
يتقون ان الله بكل شيء
عليم ان الله له ملك السماوات والارض يحيي
ويميت وما لكم من دون الله من ولي ولا
نصير لقد تاب الله على النبي
والمهاجرين
والانصار الذين اتبعوه في ساعه العسره من
بعد ما كاد يزيغ قلوب فريق
منهم ثم تاب عليهم انه بهم رؤوف
رحيم وعلى الثلاثه الذين خلفوا حتى اذا
ضاقت عليهم الارض بما رحبت وضاقت عليهم
انفسهم
وظنوا وظنوا ان ملجا من الله الا
اليه ثم تاب عليهم
ليتوبوا ان الله هو التواب
الرحيم يا ايها الذين امنوا اتقوا الله
وكونوا مع
الصادقين ما كان لاهل المدينه ومن
حولهم من الاعراب ان يتخل ل فوا عن رسول
الله ولا يرغبوا
بانفسهم عن نفسه ذلك بانهم لا يصيبهم ظما
ولا نصب ولا
مخمصه في سبيل
الله ولا يطون موطئا يغيظ الكفار ولا
ينالون من عدو نيلا الا كتب لهم به عمل
صالح ان الله لا يضيع اجر
المحسنين ولا ينفقون نفقه صغيره ولا كبيره
ولا يقطعون واديا الا كتب لهم الا كتب لهم
ليجزيهم الله احسن ما كانوا
يعملون
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وما كان الم المنون لينفروا
كافه فلولا نفر من كل فرقه منهم
طائفه ليتفقهوا في الدين ولينذروا قومهم
اذا رجعوا اليهم لعلهم
يحذرون يا ايها الذين امنوا قاتلوا الذين
يلونكم من الكفار والي فيكم غلظه واعلموا
ان الله مع
المتقين واذا ما انزلت سوره فمنهم من يقول
ايكم زادته هذه
ايمانا فاما الذين امنوا فزادتهم ايمانا
وهم
يستبشرون واما الذين في قلوبهم مرض
فزادتهم رجسا الى رجسهم وماتوا وهم
كافرون اولا يرون انهم يفتنون في كل عام
مره او مرتين ثم لا يتوبون ولا هم
يذكرون واذا ما انزلت سوره نظر بعضهم الى
بعض هل يراكم من احد
ثم انصرفوا صرف الله قلوبهم بانهم قوم لا
يفقهون لقد
جاءكم رسول من
انفسكم عزيز عليه ما عنتم حريص عليكم
بالمؤمنين رؤوف
رحيم فان تولوا فقل حسبي الله لا اله الا
هو عليه توكلت وهو رب
العرش وهو رب العرش
العظيم بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم
الم ر تلك ايات الكتاب
الحكيم اكان للناس عجبا ان اوحينا الى رجل
منهم ان انذر الناس وبشر الذين
امنوا وبشر الذين امنوا ان لهم قدم صدق
عند ربهم قال الكافرون ان هذا لساحر
مبين ان ربكم الله الذي خلق السماوات
والارض في سته ايام ثم استوى على العرش
يدبر الامر ما من شفيع الا من بعد اذنه
ذلكم الله ربكم فاعبدوه
افلا
تذكرون اليه مرجعكم جميعا وعد الله حقا
انه يبدا الخلق ثم يعيده ليجزي الذين
امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
بالقسط الذين كفروا لهم شراب من حميم
وعذاب اليم بما كانوا
يكفرون هو الذي جعل الشمس
ضياء والقمر نورا وقدره منازل وقدره منازل
لتعلموا عدد السنين
والحساب ما خلق الله ذلك الا بال الحق
يفصل الايات لقوم
يعلمون ان في اختلاف الليل والنهار وما
خلق الله في السماوات والارض لايات
لقوم
يتقون ان الذين لا يرجون
لقاءنا ورضوا بالحياه الدنيا
واطمئنوا بها
واطمان بها والذين هم عن اياتنا
غافلون
اولئك ماواهم النار بما كانوا
يكسبون ان الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
يهديهم ربهم
بايمانهم تجري من تحتهم الانهار في
جنات
دعواهم فيها سبحانك اللهم
وتحيتهم فيها
سلام واخر دعواهم ان الحمد لله رب
العالمين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
ولو يعجل الله للناس الشر
استعجالهم بالخير لقضي اليهم اجلهم فنذر
الذين لا يرجون
لقاءنا في طغيانهم
يعمهون واذا مس
الانسان الضر دعانا لجنبه او قاعدا او
قائما فلما ما كشفنا عنه ضره مرك لم يدعنا
الى ضر مسه كذلك زين للمسرفين ما كانوا
يعملون ولقد اهلكنا القرون من قبلكم لما
ظلموا
وجاءتهم رسلهم بالبينات وما كانوا
ليؤمنوا كذلك نجزي القوم المجرمين
ثم جعلناكم
خلائف في الارض من بعدهم لننظر كيف
تعملون واذا تتلى عليهم اياتنا
بينات قال الذين لا يرجون
لقاءت بقران غيرها او
بدله قل ما يكون لي ان ابدل
من
تلقاء نفسي ان اتبع الا ما يوحى الي اني
اخاف ان عصيت ربي عذاب يوم
عظيم قل لو شاء الله ما تلوته عليكم ولا
ادراكم به فقد لبثت فيكم عمرا من قبله
افلا
تعقلون فمن اظلم ممن افترى على الله كذبا
او كذب باياته انه لا يفلح
المجرمون ويعبدون من دون الله ما لا يضرهم
ولا ينفعهم ويقولون
هؤلاء
شفعاؤنا عند
الله قل اتنبئون الله بما لا يعلم في
السماوات ولا في الارض سبحانه وتعالى عما
يشركون وما كان الناس الا امه واحده
فاختلفوا ولولا كلمه سبقت من ربك لقضي
بينهم فيما فيه
يختلفون ويقولون لولا انزل عليه ايه من
ربه وقل انما الغيب لله فانتظروا اني معكم
من
المنتظرين واذا اذقنا الناس رحمه من بعد
ضرا مستهم اذا لهم مكر في
اياتنا قل الله اسرع مكرا ان رسلنا يكتبون
ما تمكر
هو الذي يسيركم في البر والبحر حتى اذا
كنتم في الفلك وجرين بهم بريح طيبه وفرحوا
بها
جاءتها ريح
عاصف
جاءتها ريح عاصف
وجاءهم الموج من كل مكان وظنوا انهم احيط
بهم دعوا
الله دعوا الله مخلصين له الدين لئن
انجيتنا من هذه
لنكونن من
الشاكرين فلما انجاهم اذا هم يبغون في
الارض بغير الحق يا ايها الناس انما بغيكم
على
انفسكم متاع الح
الدنيا ثم الينا مرجعكم فننبئهم بما كنتم
تعملون انما مثل الحياه الدنيا
كما ان
انزلناه من
السماء فاختلط به نبات الارض فاختلط به
نبات الارض مما ياكل الناس
والانعام
حتى اذا اخذت الارض زخرفها وازينت وظن
اهلها انهم قادرون عليها اتاها امرنا ليلا
او
نهارا اتاها امرنا ليلا او نهارا فجعلناها
حصيدا كان لم تغنى
بالامس كذلك نفصل الايات لقوم
يتفكرون
والله يدعو الى دار
السلام ويهدي من
يشاء الى
صراط
مستقيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم راط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين والله يدعو الى دار السلام ويهدي من
يشاء الى صراط
مستقيم للذي احسنوا الحسنى وزياده ولا
يرهق وجوههم قتر ولا ذله
اولئك اصحاب الجنه هم فيها
خالدون والذين كسبوا السيئات
جزاء سيئه بمثلها وترهقهم ذله ما لهم من
الله من
عاصم كانما اغشيت وجوههم قطعا من الليل
مظلما
اولئك اصحاب
النار هم فيها
خالدون ويوم نحشرهم جميعا ثم نقول للذين
اشركوا مكانكم انتم
وشركاؤكم فزيلنا
بينهم فزيلنا
بينهم وقال
شر والذين كسبوا السيئات
جزاء سيئه بمثلها وترهقهم ذله وترهقهم ذله
ما لهم من الله من عاصم كانما اغشيت
وجوههم قطعا من الليل مظلما اولئك اصحاب
النار هم فيها
خالدون ويوم نحشرهم جميعا ثم نقول للذين
اشركوا مكانكم انتم
وشركاؤكم فزيلنا بينهم وقال
شركاؤهم ما كنتم ايانا
تعبدون فكفى بالله شهيدا بيننا وبينكم ان
كنا عن عبادتكم
لغافلين هنالك تبلو كل نفس ما اسلفت وردوا
الى الله مولاهم الحق وضل عنهم ما كانوا
يفترون قل من يرزقكم من
السماء والارض امن يملك السمع
والابصار ومن يخرج الحي من الم يت ويخرج
الميت من الحي ومن يدبر الامر فسيقولون
الله فقل افلا
تتقون فذلكم الله ربكم الحق فماذا بعد
الحق الا الضلال فانا
تصرفون كذلك حقت كلمه ربك على الذين فسقوا
انهم لا يؤمنون
قل هل من
شركائكم من يبدا الخلق ثم يعيده قل الله
يبدا الخلق ثم يعيده فانا
تؤفكون قل هل من
شركائكم من يهدي الى الحق قل الله يهدي
للحق افمن يهدي الى الحق احق ان يتبع امن
لا يهدي الا ان يهدى فما لكم كيف
تحكمون وما يتبع اكثرهم الا
ظنا ان الظن لا يغني من الحق شيئا ان الله
عليم بما
يفترون ان الله عليم بما يفعلون وما كان
هذا القران ان يفترى من دون الله ولكن
تصديق الذي بين يديه وتفصيل الكتاب لا ريب
فيه من رب
العالمين ام يقولوا ن
افتراه قل فاتوا بسوره مثله وادعوا من
استطعتم من دون الله ان كنتم
صادقين بل كذ
بما لم يحيطوا بعلمه ولما ياتهم تاويله
كذلك كذب الذين من قبلهم فانظر كيف كان
عاقبه
الظالمين ومنهم من يؤمن به ومنهم من لا
يؤمن به وربك اعلم بالمفسدين
فان كذب كذبوك فقل لي عملي ولكم عملكم
انتم
بريئون مما اعمل وانا
بريء
مما
تعملون ومنهم من يستمعون اليك افانت تسمع
الصم ولو كانوا لا
يسمعون لا يعقلون ومنهم من ينظر اليك اف ت
تهدي العمي ولو كانوا لا
يبصرون ان الله لا يظلم الناس شيئا
ولكن الناس
انفسهم
يظلمون ويوم يحشرهم كان لم يلبثوا الا
ساعه من النهار يتعارفون بينهم قد خسر
الذين كذبوا
بلقاء الله وما كانوا
مهتدين
واما نرينك بعض الذين عدهم او نتوفينك
فالينا مرجعهم ثم الله شهيد على ما
يفعلون ولكل امه رسول فاذا
جاء رسولهم قضي بينهم بالقسط وهم لا
يظلمون
ويقولون متى هذا الوعد ان كنتم
صادقين قل لا املك لنفسي ضرا ولا نفعا الا
ما
شاء الله لكل امه اجل لكل امه اجل اذا
جاء اجلهم فلا يستاخرون
ساعه ولا يستقدمون
قل ارايتم ان اتاكم عذابه بياتا او
نهارا ماذا يستعجل منه
المجرمون اثم اذا ما وقع
امنتم
به الان وقد كنتم به
تستعجلون ثم قيل للذين ظلموا ذوقوا عذاب
الخلد هل تجزون الا بما
كنتم
تكسبون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
استغفر
[Silence]
‏in
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم صلاه والسلام على رسول الله وعلى
اله وصحبه ومن ولاه ومن تبعه باحسان ي
الدين
بعد شا
الله
ان شاء
الله عبد
المبول الله
صلى
ابوب
[Silence]
اللهب
‏some
come
rest
‏caran come and taking some water and
there is a young man that every he go
the cloud follows the
way tree
tree
him
‏other mon to and
them caran
that
mon
reg
[Silence]
‏all
all
‏guante
my
possible
my fathered care
‏trange
right you know remind حديث رسول الله صل
علسلم حديث جبريل فيساله
فيصدقه جبريل
question confused he asking question
say why would you ask question if you
know the anw
so he tells
‏in the
[Silence]
name
‏ask
tr now numbers are adding up for him
right he has g down his checklist he
added everything so now he wants to see
the
se
accra se
in
of ask per
رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
notus thew find out will
be ابوطالب
الله
صل
because
الله
[Silence]
محكر عن
‏the prev
indic
people
يه
jew
اللهه
علسلام
ابم and as was a a slave woman know
as of
them
عليه
عليه what we see today world a world war
basically stage has been for for this
stat الله سبحانه
وتالى fin
علسلام الله سبحانه
وتالى سهال
[Silence]
ال
اللهه اله الله محد رسول
الله
ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه
وقنا عذاب النار وقنا عذاب القبر وقنا
عذاب جنم وقنا عذاب فتنه محيا والممات
وقنا عذاب فتنه مسيح الدجال ربنا تقبل منا
انك السميع العليم وتوب علينا يا مولانا
انك التواب الرحيم وصلى على محمد وعلى اله
وصحبه اجمعين برحمتك ارحم الراحمين اللهم
امين اللهم امين اللهم
امين
[Silence]
استقيم اعتدلوا
استو سد
الخلل
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا
الضالين
امين
ويستنبئونك
احق هو قل اي وربي انه لحق وما انتم
بمعجزين ولو ان لكل نفس ظلمت ما في الارض
لافتدت
به واسروا الندامه لما راوا
العذاب وقضي بينهم بالقسط وهم لا
يظلمون الا ان لله ما في السماوات
والارض الا ان وعد الله حق
ولكن اكثرهم لا
يعلمون هو يحيي ويميت واليه
ترجعون يا ايها الناس قد
جاءتكم
موعظه من
ربكم
وشفاء لما في
الصدور
وهدى ورحمه
للمؤمنين
قل بفضل الله
وبرحمته فبذلك
فليفرحوا هو خير مما
يجمعون قل ارايتم ما انزل الله لكم من رزق
فجعلتم
فجعلتم منه حراما
وحلالا
قل الله اذن لكم ام على الله
تفترون وما ظنوا الذين يفترون على الله
الكذب يوم
القيامه ان الله لذو فضل على الناس ولكن
اكثر الناس لا
يشكرون
ولكن اكثرهم لا يشكرون
وما تكون في شان وما تتلوا منه من قران
ولا
تعملون ولا تعملون من عمل الا كنا عليكم
شهودا اذ تفيضون
فيه وما يعزب عن ربك من مثقال ذره في
الارض ولا في
السماء ولا اصغر من ذلك ولا اكبر الا في
كتاب
مبين الا ان
اولياء الله لا خوف عليهم ولا هم
يحزنون الذين امنوا وكانوا
يتقون لهم البشرى في الحياه لهم البشرى في
الحياه الدنيا وفي
الاخره لا تبديل لكلمات الله ذلك هو الفوز
العظيم ولا يحزنك قولهم
ان العزه لله جميعا
انه هو السميع العليم الا ان
لله ان العزه لله جميعا هو السميع العليم
الا ان لله من في السماوات والارض الا ان
لله من في السماوات ومن في
الارض وما يتبع الذين يدعون من دون الله
شركاء يتبعون الا
الظن وان هم الا
يخرصون هو الذي جعل لكم الليل لتسكنوا فيه
والنهار
مبصرا ان في ذلك لايات لقوم
يسمعون قالوا اتخذ الله
ولدا
سبحانه هو الغني له ما في السماوات وما في
الارض ان
عندكم من
سلطان
بهذا اتقولون على الله ما لا
تعلمون ان الذين يفترون على الله الكذب لا
يفلحون
متاع في الحياه الدنيا
ثم الينا
مرجعهم ان الذين يفترون على الله الكذب لا
يفلحون قل ان الذين يفترون على الله الكذب
لا
يفلحون متاع في الحياه
الدنيا
ثم ث الينا
مرجعهم متاع في الدنيا ثم الينا
مرجعهم ثم نذيقهم
العذاب الشديد بما كانوا
يكفرون الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين واتل عليهم نباى نوح اذ قال لقومه يا
قوم ان كان كبر عليكم
مقامي يا قوم ان كان كبر عليكم مقامي
وتذكيري بايات
الله فعليه توكلت فعلى الله توكلت فاجمعوا
امركم
وشركاءكم ثم لا يكن امركم عليكم غمه ثم
اقضوا الي ولا
تنظرون
فان توليتم فما
سالتكم من اجر ان اجري الا على الله وامرت
ان اكون من
المسلمين فكذبوه فنجيناه
ومن معه في الفلك
وجعلناهم
خلائف واغرقنا الذين كذبوا
باياتنا ف انظر كيف كان عاقبه
المنذرين ثم بعثنا من بعدده رسلا الى
قومهم
فجاؤهم
بالبينات فما كانوا ليؤمنوا بما كذبوا به
من قبل كذلك نطبع على قلوب
المعتدين ثم بعثنا من بعدهم موسى
وهارون الى فرعون وملاه
باياتنا فاستكبروا
وكانوا قوما
مجرمين فلما
جاءهم الحق من ربهم
قالوا فلما
جاءهم الحق من عندنا قالوا
قالوا ان هذا قالوا ان هذا الا سحر
مبين قالوا ان هذا ان هذا لسحر مبين قال
موسى اتقولون للحق لما
جاءكم اسحر هذا ولا يفلح
الساحرون قالوا جئتنا لتلفتنا
عما وجدنا عليه
اباءنا وتكون لكما
الكبرياء في الارض وما نحن لكما
بمؤمنين وقال فرعون ائتوني بكل ساحر
عليم فلما
جاء السحره قال لهم موسى القوا ما انتم
ملقون
فلما القوا قال موسى
انما جئتم به قال موسى ما جئتم به السحر
ان الله
سيبطله ان الله لا يصلح عمل
المفسدين ويحق الله
الحق ويحق الله الحق ويقطع دا ويحق الله
الحق ولو كره المجرمين ولو كره
المجرمون ويحق الله الحق ولو كره
المجرمون ويحق الله الحق
بك ويحق الله الحق
بكلماته ولو كره
المجرمون فما امن لموسى الا
ذريه من قومه على خوف من
فرعون على خوف من فرعون وملئهم ان
يفتنهم وان فرعون لعال في الارض وانه لمن
المسرفين
وقال موسى يا قوم ان كنتم
امنتم بالله فعليه
توكلوا فعليه توكلوا ان كنتم مسلمين
فقالوا على الله
توكلنا ربنا لا تجعلنا فته للقوم
الظالمين ونجنا برحمتك من القوم
الكافرين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
واوحينا الى موسى واخيه ان تبوا لقومكما
بمصر بيوتا واجعلوا بيوتكم قبله واقيموا
الصلاه وبشر
المؤمنين وقال موسى ربنا انك اتيت فرعون
وملاه زينه واموالا في الحياه
الدنيا ربنا ليضلوا عن
سبيلك ربنا اطمس على اموالهم واسدد على
قلوبهم فلا يؤمنوا حتى يروا العذاب الاليم
قال قد اجيبت
دعوتكما فاستقيما ولا
تتبع سبيل الذين لا يعلمون
وجاوزنا ببني
اسرائيل البحر فاتبعهم فرعون وجنوده بغيا
وعدوى حتى اذا ادركه الغرق قال امنت انه
لا اله الا الذي امنت به بنو
اسرائيل حتى اذا ادركه الغرق قال امنت انه
اسرائيل وانا من
المسلمين الان وقد عصيت قبل
وكنت من
المفسدين فاليوم ننجيك ببدنك لتكون لمن
خلفك
ايه وان وان كثيرا وان كثيرا من الناس عن
اياتنا
لغافلون وان كثيرا من الناس عن اياتنا
لغافلون فان كنت في شك مما انزلنا اليك
فاسال الذين يقراون القران من قبلك
ولقد بوانا بني
اسرائيل مبوا صدق
ورزقناهم من
الطيبات فما اختلفوا حتى
جاءهم العلم ان ربك يقضي بينهم يوم
القيامه فيما كانوا فيه
يختلفون فان كنت في شك مما انزلنا اليك
فاسال الذين يقرون الكتاب من قبلك لقد
جاءك الحق من ربك فلا
تكونن من الممترين
ولا
تكونن من الذين كذبوا بايات الله فتكون من
الخاسرين ان ان الذين حقت عليهم كلمه ربك
لا
يؤمنون ولو
جاءتهم كل ايه حتى يروا العذاب
الاليم الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم راط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين فلولا كانت قريه امنت فنفعها ايمانها
الا قوم يونس الا قوم يونس لما امنوا
كشفنا عن هم عذاب الخزي في الحياه الدنيا
ومتعناهم الى حين ولو شاء ربك لامن من في
الارض كلهم
جميعا
افانت تكره
الناس حتى يكونوا مؤمنين وما كان لنفس ان
تؤمن الا باذن الله ويجعل الرجس على الذين
لا
يؤمنون ويجعل الرجس على الذين لا
يعقلون قل انظروا ماذا في السماوات وما في
الارض قل انظروا ماذا في السماوات والارض
وما تغني الايات والنذر عن قوم لا
يؤمنون فهل انتظرون الا مثل ايام الذين
خلوا من
قبل قل
فانتظروا
اني معكم من
المنتظرين
ثم ننجي رسلنا والذين
امنوا كذلك حقا علينا ننجي
المؤمنين قل يا ايها الناس ان كنتم في شك
من
ديني فلا اعبدوا الذين تعبدون من دون الله
ولكن اعبدوا الذي
يتوفاكم ولكن اعبد الله الذي
يتوفاكم ولكن اعبدوا الله الذي
يتوفاكم وامرت ان اكون من
المسلمين وامرت ان اكون من
المؤمنين وان اقم وجهك للدين حنيفا ولا
تكونن من
المشركين ولا تدع من دون الله ما لا
ينفعك لا يضرك فان فعلت انك اذا من
الظالمين فان فعلت فانك اذا اذا من
الظالمين وان يمسسك الله بضر فلا كاشف فلا
كاشف له الا
هو وان يردك بخير فلا را
د لفضله يصيب به من
يشاء من عباده وهو الغفور
الرحيم قل يا ايها الناس قد
جاءكم الحق من
ربكم فمن اهتدى فانما يهتدي لنفسه ومن ضل
فانما ما يضل
عليها وما انا
عليكم بوكيل واتبع ما يوحى اليك واصبر
واصبر حتى يحكم
الله وهو خير
الحاكمين بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الم
را كتاب احكمت اياته ثم
فصلت من لدن حكيم خبير الا تعبدوا الا
الله
انني لكم منه نذير وبشير وان استغفروا
ربكم ثم توبوا
اليه
يمتعكم متاعا حسنا الى اجل
مسمى ويؤت كلذ
فضل فضله وان تولوا فاني اخاف عليكم عذاب
يوم كبير الى الله مرجعكم وهو على كل شيء
قدير الا انهم يثنون صدورهم ليستخفوا منه
الا حين يستغشون
ثيابهم يعلم ما يسرون وما
يعلنون
انه عليم بذات
الصدور الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
‏s
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
شف
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين
بسم الله الرحمن ال ويل لكل همزه لمزه
الذي جمع مالا
وعدده يحسب ان
مه
اخلده كلا
لينبذن في الحطمه وما ادراك ما
الحطمه نار الله
الموقده التي تطلع على
الافئده
انها عليهم مؤصده في عمد
ممدده الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين ان عمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم الله الرحمن اذا
جاء نصر الله
والفتح ورايت الناس يدخلون في دين الله
افواجا فسبح بحمد ربك
واستغفر
انه كان
توابا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
صل اللهم بارك على
م
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله بسم
الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت
عليه غير المغضب عليه ولا
الضالين
امين بسم الله ال ق هو الله احد الله
الصمد يلد ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده اللهم انا نشهد انك بينت الله لا اله
الا انت الواحد الاحد الفرض صمد الذي لم
يلد ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا احد اللهم
انت الحق ولقاك الحق وجنه الحق والنار
الحق وساعه الحق ونبينا حق ونبينا محمد
صلى الله عليه وسلم حق اللهم بك امنا
وعليك توكلنا ويك نا وبك خمنا فاغفر لنا
ما قدمنا وما اخرنا فانت المقدم وان
الموخر وانت على كل شيء
قدير اللهم اهدنا فيمن هديت وعافنا في من
عافيت وتولنا في من توليت وبارك لنا فيما
اعطيت وكنا واصرف عنا برحمتك شر ما ضيت
انك تقضي ولا يقضى عليك انه لا يذل من
واليت ولا يعز من عاديت تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا اللهم اغفر
لنا ذنوبنا اللهم اغفر لنا ذنوبنا وان لم
تغفر لنا وترحمنا لونن من الخاسرين
اللهم انك عفو تحب العفو فاعفو عنا اللهم
انك عفو تحب العفو
فعفونا اللهم انك عفو كريم تحب العفو
فعفونا اللهم انصر الاسلام
والمسلمين اللهم انصر دينك وكتابك اللهم
انصر نبيك محمد وعبادك
الصالحين اذ لا شرك
والمشركين ودمر اعداء الدين يا قوي يا
عزيز اللهم اعتق رقابنا من النار ورقاب
والدينا
وذريتنا
وازواجنا وارحمنا وادخلنا جنه مع
الابرار يا عزيز يا
غفار اللهم يا سامع الصوت ويا سابق الف
و كاسيا عظام لحما بعد الموت اغفر لجميع
الموتى المسلمين الذين شهدك بالوحدانيه
ونبيك بالرساله وماتوا على ذلك اللهم اغفر
لهم وارحمهم وعافهم وعفو عنهم واكرم نزلهم
ووسع مدخلهم واغسلهم بالماء ثلج والبرد
ونقهم من الذنوب والخطايا كما ين كما ينق
الثوب الابيد من الدنس ومتعنا اللهم
باسماعنا وابصارنا
وقواتنا ابدا ما احييتنا واجعله الوارث
منا واجعل ثارنا على من ظلمنا وانصرنا على
من عادانا ولا تسلط علينا بذنوبنا و بمن
لا يخاف فينا ولا يرحمنا اللهم عز جارك
وجل ثناؤك وتقدس اسماؤك اللهم لا يرد امرك
ولا يحزن جندك اللهم اعد المسجد الاقصى
الى رحاب المسلمين اللهم اد المسجد الاقصى
الى رحاب
المسلمين وارزقنا فيه صلاه قبل الممات
اللهم انصر اخوان المستضعفين في فلسطين
وغزه اللهم انصر اخوان المستضعفين في كل
مكان اللهم انصر اخوان المسلمين في كل
مكان ربنا تقبل منا انك انت السميع العليم
وتوب علينا يا مولانا انك انت التواب
الرحيم وصلى الله على محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين برحمتك يا ارحم
الراحمين الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام
الا الله
اشهد اللهم صل
على ربي اجعلني مقيم
[Silence]
الصلا السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
ان